how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there has been a lot of news and leaks
about guardians of the galaxy volume
three and even though it's not coming
out until 2022 it's getting really
exciting to hear all about what we can
expect to see in the movie and one of
the leaks that we've gotten is that the
High Evolutionary is actually going to
be the main villain in guardians of the
galaxy volume 3 and this has some people
confused because they thought that Adam
warlock was supposed to be the main
villain and now a lot of people are
wondering if we're even going to get
Adam warlock in guardians of the galaxy
volume 3 but don't worry I'm going to
break down everything you need to know
about guardians of the galaxy 3 and Adam
warlock in this video but first a quick
reminder about my giveaway when I hit
450,000 subscribers I will be giving
away 3 Marvel Legends series items and
then when I hit 500,000 subscribers I'll
be doing a huge giveaway for half a
million subs so be sure to subscribe to
my channel so you can enter I picked
three winners for the 400,000 subscriber
giveaway last night you can find the
giveaway winner video in the link up
above so in the post credits scene for
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 they
showed Adam warlocks cocoon teasing that
he is going to be the villain of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 Alicia
said that she made Adam warlock to
destroy the guardians of the galaxy
james gunn directed guardians of the
galaxy volume 1 and volume 2 and he had
the contract to do guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 so this was James Gunn's
plan he was setting up Adam warlock to
appear in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
but then James Gunn got fired and then
rehired and now there is a leak going
around that the High Evolutionary is
going to be the main villain of volume 3
the leak comes from a very credible
source Roger Wardell who was right about
many Avengers in-game leaks months
before the movie even came out but don't
worry Adam warlock is still going to
debut in guardians 3 the thing is Adam
warlock isn't supposed to be the main
villain of guardians 3 yes he will start
off as a villain going up against the
Guardians and most likely Thor but Adam
warlock actually is not a villain he has
been known to partner with Fano
sometimes but he isn't a villain he's
actually a hero so at some point in time
Adam warlock is actually going to stop
going against the Guardians and he is
still confirmed to be in the
and the reason we know this is that
guardians of the galaxy 3 still has the
same script James Gunn has had the
guardians 3 script done for a very long
time and of course that script included
Adam warlock it was set up in the last
Guardians movie but when he got fired
people were wondering what is going to
happen to volume 3
but even though James Gunn got fired we
learned that Marvel was actually still
using the script that he wrote for
volume 3 and this was confirmed by
several people including some of the
actors working also change the script
presumably it sounds like you guys are
yeah you read the script GIF it's off
the chain so so and then when James Gunn
got rehired he came out and said that
he's still going to use the same script
that he had before in a recent interview
with deadlines he said that he had plans
to end Rocket Raccoon story arc in
guardians 3 and when he got fired he was
still happy to hear that they were going
to use his same script and then he said
that he's happy to be back on the
project and he's happy to continue and
finish Rocket Raccoon story arc so the
script is still the same which means the
introduction of Adam warlock and
Guardians 3 is still there James Gunn
has been planning to introduce Adam
warlock since the very first guardians
of the galaxy film and now that he's
back directing the film nothing has
changed Adam warlock is still going to
be introduced in guardians volume 3 yes
there have been reports that the High
Evolutionary is going to be the main
villain of guardians 3 but that does not
change the fact that Adam warlock will
be introduced in the movie and we will
most likely see him team up with the
guardians of the galaxy to go against
the High Evolutionary and he'll probably
play a pretty significant role moving
forward in the MCU so for those of you
who have been worried don't worry James
Gunn has confirmed he is still going to
use the same script that he had for
guardians 3 and that means that Adam
warlock is still confirmed to enter the
MCU in guardians of the galaxy volume 3
so let me know how excited you are to
finally see Adam warlock appear in the
MCU and go up against the guardians of
the galaxy at least for a part of the
movie be sure to let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again a reminder about my giveaway at
the 450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking 3 winners to choose one item
each from the Marvel Legends series
collection and then at the 500,000
subscriber Mike I will be doing a
massive giveaway that I will announce
soon if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have
do is be subscribed to my channel like
this video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain I'll also be doing
some giveaways on my Instagram and on my
Twitter so if you want some more chances
to win follow me on those as always
thank you all so much for watching you
said it'd cost you everything while
crying like a baby